bonjour à tous bienvenue sur l'antenne
de public sénat dans un instant les
traditionnelles questions d'actualité
nous sommes jeudi au sénat ce sont les
traditionnels quai sur l'actualité on va
bien sûr développer toute l'actualité du
sénat dans un instant il ya de
nombreuses questions qui sont posées
notamment sur le chômage deux questions
très importantes sur le chômage d'ici
quinze minutes mais d'abord on va
développer toute l'actualité politique
et parlementaire avec mon avis tu es
marylise lebranchu bonjour vous êtes
l'ami de la décentralisation de la
fonction publique on va aborder les
sujets qui vous touche dans votre
ministère d'ici quelques minutes tout
d'abord je voudrais votre réaction sur
l' annonce du président de la république
qui a demandé qu'un projet de loi
constitutionnelle permettant la
ratification d'une certaine charte
européenne très clairement sur les
langues régionales puisse aujourd'hui
être votée c'est un projet de loi ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir réunir le
congrès à versailles est-ce que déjà
vous ça vous séduit ça vous plaît je
sais que vous êtes proche de la bretagne
est ce que ce sera possible
je suis pas surpris que je plaide
effectivement cela depuis longtemps est
le président la république s'y était
engagé pendant sa campagne électorale et
après les votes qui sont intervenus
en particulier avec
l'initiative de jean-jacques urvoas à
l'assemblée nationale on peut si on
entend à la fois bien sûr camille de
rocca serra marc lefur ou d'autres on
peut imaginer que cette majorité requise
est possible en tout cas moi je l'espère
et je l'appelle le mais veut parce qu'on
ne peut pas sur le territoire se battre
pour les langues régionales et ne plus
les voter en congrès pour la
ratification voilà pour expliquer un
petit pot téléspectateurs ça veut dire
quoi concrètement c'est à dire que si on
prend votre exemple la langue bretonne
par exemple elle sera reconnu par la
république française et après alors nous
allons d'abord c'est la ratification
d'une charte européenne de
reconnaissance des langues régionales
terrasse est reconnue 10 ans 92 pas la
biocoop et donc nous nous avions déjà
préparé avec lionel jospin la
ratification et ça a été refusé à
l'époque par le président la république
jacques chirac à la demande du rpr au
titre que ça entraînait trop
d'obligations de traduction et c'est
donc on a fait attention à ce que met on
fait attention à ce que les obligations
soient naturellement acceptable en
termes par exemple de fonctionnaires
traducteur des choses de ceux de ce type
mais ce qui est très important d'abord
c'est une reconnaissance officielle
européenne et officiels pour nous c'est
comme disait jacques lang très justement
en son temps c'est une réparation de la
république envers ces langues régionales
et ça permettra nous en terme de droit
après je discutais l'autre jour de la
compétence ici même au sénat langues
régionales
avec la commission des lois qui était un
peu réticente elle le sera sans doute
beaucoup moins gras vous imaginez que la
commission des lois ici qui est présidée
par rappeler les républicains
aujourd'hui tout cas le parti de la
droite vous imaginez tu serais d'accord
pour participer à ce vote du congrès
j'ai fait remarquer à certains qui s'est
exprimé au banc les débats sont publics
et je peux citer monsieur bah qui disait
un moment donné l'élan d'un journal
c'est essentiellement de la culture donc
je pense que les langues régionales ce
n'est pas que de la culture c'est aussi
de l'éducation c'est le nombre de
locuteurs et surtout ne pas abandonner
les langues régionales alors l'histoire
en faire vraiment des éléments de vie et
c'est ça qui est important à partir de
septembre ne voyait pas de malice
politicienne derrière mais cette loi est
bloqué au sénat depuis le 28 janvier
2014 à l'époque c'était la gauche qui
était au pouvoir hausser leur
jeu vous savez c'est est toujours très
difficile débat avec les républicains le
fait générateur de cette histoire
particulière c'est l'engagement du
président de la république pendant sa
campagne électorale en bretagne
d'ailleurs à l'époque et le fait que
l'assemblée nationale ait voté de façon
transparente izan ce texte donc je pense
qu'ici pas les renvoyer la balle est
renvoyée au sénat et je pense que le
sénat doit la saisir et juste derrière
que sur ce point il faut que ça aille
vite vous devant une certaine urgence
sur ce texte il faut un oral venir
l'inaugurer le plus vite possible on
aurait bien voulu vous savez il faut
aussi respecter les parlementaires le
président de la république qui tient
elle premier ministre aussi donc on
respectera toujours les parlementaires
dont il va donner dans le temps vous
voyez pas ça la tradition c'est le plus
vite possible je voudrais vous faire
réagir sur cette une c'est l'umps qui a
fait c'était une ce matin avec le
président de la république avec des
lunettes de soleil célèbre mais c'est le
titre qui m'inquiète un peu plus en tout
cas pour vous le ps est il de droite
pour l'interrogation évidemment votre
réaction non nous sommes des
républicains socialistes républicains de
gauche est vraiment très à gauche et je
pense que quand j'ai dit très à gauche
être à gauche c'est avoir une conception
de la société une conception de la
république une conception de l'équité et
de l'égalité
c'est donner priorité à l'école c'est
croire en la force de 200 pays bref nous
nous sommes de gauche
et quand le débat porte sur gauche
droite en général ils portent sur
le cic e par élève qui a été donnée aux
entreprises pour baisser le coût du
travail moi je réponds toujours le
projet socialiste
avant les élections présidentielles
disait il faut relancer la stratégie
industrielle en france on avait besoin
de cet aspect compétitivité mais le
débat il faut toujours la voir la patte
et normand vous l'avez au sein d'autres
pour partager votre point de discorde et
frondeur apparemment qui que ce soit se
pose la question il faut conduire le
débat et je pense que la lecture d'une
action publique est une lecture
difficile parce qu'on vit beaucoup dans
l'immédiateté dans dans le présent et
est du coup l'annoncé faite hier on
voudrait qu'elle soit appliquée le
lendemain et et on oublie parfois et
c'est peut-être de reproche que je nous
fais collectivement à tous les
politiques de parler de notre projet de
société dans sa globalité et pas
seulement des mesures que nous devenons
prendre d'où l'intérêt d'avoir des
grands discours sur la république quand
on est à gauche comme l'a fait il n'ya
pas très longtemps le président hollande
alors là une évidemment elle est pas
innocent parce qu'à partir de demain
commence le congrès du parti socialiste
à poitiers pendant presque trois jours
vous le voyez comment ce congrès
certains disent que c'est le congrès de
la clarification ou d'autres au
contraire comme les fraudeurs qui vont
dire c'est le congrès on va essayer de
pousser encore les feux un petit peu
plus loin et pour montrer qu'il ya une
vraie différence au sein de ce parti moi
je pense que c'est important que tout le
monde pousse les feux et ceux qui ont
signé telle et telle tendance toujours
poussé leur c'est quoi pousser des feux
s'est affirmée des convictions dans un
débat il faut que les convictions soit
affirmé il faut qu'il ya un débat et
après le débat y aura une majorité moi
je crois au débat je crois qu'il est
toujours enrichissant ce que je regrette
pour la france c'est que entre la
majorité actuelle qui soutient le
gouvernement et l'opposition en national
il ya plus de caricatures que débat donc
je pense que mon parti donne une belle
image de ce qui est le débat même si
c'est difficile je vous ai promis on va
revenir sur vos textes très rapidement
d'allergie à condition bien sûr vous
parliez des républicains je voudrais
juste votre réaction nicolas sarkozy a
demandé que ce soit au groupe à
l'assemblée nationale où groupe l'est
républicain ici au sénat une proposition
à une proposition de loi pour abroger
tous les textes qui ont été faits anti
entreprise dit il arrive qu'ils les
trouvent qu'ils me le disent
où sont les textes anti entreprises mais
il faut surtout que l'opposition
actuelle
face comment dire homo génie ses
positions prenez françois marin
président de la mef ici au sénat avec le
sénateur demande plus de dotations plus
de dépenses publiques
pas ralentir les dotations aux
collectivités locales c'est plus de
dépenses publiques c'est peut-être un
peu de dettes vous avez un livre qui
sort de monsieur woerth ou d'eau et
moins de dépenses publiques
certains me disent plus département
d'autres il veut toucher
des fonctionnaires pas bon je trouve
qu'il n'ya pas et c'est à regret
toujours dans une majorité de ne pas
avoir une opposition qui se construit
qui construit son propre projet et qu'on
puisse discuter projet par contre projet
les mesures anti entreprise si vous me
trouvez une ici le mot s'il peut me
donner une qui soit vraiment une mesure
anti entreprises franchement là c'est de
la caricature parce que il veille à
turin oui c'est une caricature quand eux
le week-end dernier il tape très fort
quand même sur françois hollande sur
l'action du gouvernement qu'est-ce qu'il
fait nicolas sark de la caricature est
une caricature qui est dangereuse parce
qu'on doit toujours respecter la
fonction et à force de ne pas faire de
propositions mais de simplement de taper
sur l'autre ça fait ça donne un résultat
terrifiant c'est que les français ne
s'intéressent pas à la politique
les joutes politiques ne les intéresse
pas ce qui les intéresse à l'avenir de
leur propre société bien sûr leur vie
mais la société dans laquelle ils vivent
et là malheureusement on est bon on en
est bien loin des propos faire évoluer
la partie madame le brunch je peux me
permettre votre propre parti ils
n'étaient que 70 milles à prendre part
au vote oui votre passion qui est posée
à la fois à la majorité à l'opposition à
tous les partis politiques pour pourquoi
deux événements majeurs pourquoi les
gens ne se déplacent que pour aller
voter pourquoi ne font-ils plus
confiance alors j'ai dû aussi parce que
parfois ils n'ont pas d'espoir donc
c'est important de leur parler de
société et d'espoir et pourquoi les
militants ne se déplace plus c'est parce
qu'ils ont l'impression peut-être qu'on
les écoute moi donc il faut rénover les
méthodes de travail et je crois que le
congrès va être le moment de parler
méthodes de travail avec la mission par
le premier secrétaire qui et c'est très
important parce qu'il n'ya pas de
démocratie sans parti politique il n'ya
pas de vie politique intéressante sans
débat profond et pas de débat sur des
petites phrases et petits mots ou des
petites choses ministre de la
décentralisation de la fonction publique
on y va il ya eu de cesse vote au sénat
au début de semaine sur ce qu'on appelle
la loi notre la loi nôtre c'est
l'organisation territoriale de la
république de la république au sénat
sénat de droite le vote a été différent
de ce que vous vouliez oui est-ce que
vous avez l'impression d'avoir une vue
de la france à l'assemblée et une vue
celle du sénat je pense que je le dis en
toute franchise et sans polémique les
sénateurs parfois regarde ce projet par
les autres ils font très bien leur
boulot de législateur comme s'il était
là le haut conseil des territoires
qu'ils demandent d'être c'est-à-dire
représentants des exécutifs c'est arrivé
parfois dans les débats moi je pense que
le sénat chaque sénateur fait la loi il
va faire la loi à l'aune de l'action
publique vu par les citoyens pas par les
présidents de départements président de
région c'est ce qu'ils essayent de faire
mais parfois je comprends que élu par
des élus ils soient parfois porte-voix
des élus locaux ce qu'ils doivent être
aussi donc c'est compliqué pour le sénat
c'est compliqué moi j'entends cette
complexité mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
21e siècle il faut qu'on soit
extrêmement rationnelle sur l'action
publique qui fait quoi et quand on
demande aux de supprimer la clause de
compétence générale ici au sénat s'est
formidablement bien c'est bienvenu c'est
bien entendu et je suis de celles qui
trouve que ce retour de la majorité vers
cette position de fans la clause de
compétence générale sur le droit de tout
faire est une bonne chose mais quand on
refait revenir toutes les compétences
qu'on a fait sortir par la porte par la
fenêtre l'immobilier d'entreprise au
département et puis une partie des
transports et puis faut faire attention
nous avons une situation budgétaire qui
est une situation qui peut mettre en
danger la souveraineté nationale de
notre pays donc soyons donc très clair
il est rationnel parce que tous les
territoires de france fasse des efforts
que
mais qu'ensuite et avec les sénateurs
comme avec les députés on fasse que les
dotations de l'état aux collectivités
locales soient plus justes aujourd'hui
c'est injuste je rends hommage et avec
grand regret à jean germain qui a
détrôné un regret ce bonne a rendu un
magnifique rapport sur les inégalités
dans les dotations de l'état on doit y
répondre
bien sûr par l'écriture des compétences
aujourd'hui mais aussi par une réforme
que demande le premier ministre est
présent dans public sur les dotations
d'état qui est attendu ce que vous
parlez des dotations de l'état de jean
germain bien évidemment il ya un autre
fait divers il ya une sorte de
ras-le-bol des mères aussi qu'ils se
sentent serré à la gorge et qui nous
plaît on a même vu une enquête du
parisien aujourd'hui que dans certaines
cantines on ne pourra plus payer le
repas scolaires il faut faire très
attention
d'abord parce que mr c'est une fonction
difficile mais il faut faire attention
et respecter les personnes qui est
malheureusement met fin à leurs jours
dans des circonstances tout à fait
différent moi ce que je pense
aujourd'hui c'est que
il ya une grande injustice entre les
territoires l'inégalité entre les
territoires et trop violente et en
baissant la notation si on baissait de
la même façon à tout le monde on ferait
une erreur donc nous ce qu'on veut faire
en même temps c'est rendre justice aux
territoires il ya des communes rurales
qui vont très bien et des communes
rurales qui vont très mal il faut qu'on
regarde pourquoi qu'elle est quelle est
l'histoire qui fait que quelque part et
vers n'en peut plus non il faut on
trouvera des il faut qu'on trouve des
critères objectifs et qu'on aide ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin parce que
parfois il ya des critiques de nos
citoyens sur tel et tel somptueuse
médiathèque tel est l mairie refaite
j'entends ça je le vois même ça sur
certains certaines images de télévision
donc soyons attention actions publiques
nécessaires nécessaires au développement
du pays nécessaires à l'accès aux droits
nécessaires aux services publics mais
avec justice avec des territoires qu'ils
soient mieux traités qu'ils ne le sont
aujourd'hui je n'oublie pas que vous
avez aussi la fonction publique dans
votre ministère il ya eu des annonces
qui ont été faites pour un certain
nombre d'emplois aidés près de 100000 en
plus ce qui arrivera prête plus de cinq
cent mille emplois aidés sur le
quinquennat vous estimez vous que c'est
un effort que doit faire aussi la
fonction publique l'effort doit être
fait par tous par exemple moi je vais
ouvrir davantage de postes en
apprentissage avait demandé au président
de la république nous n'avions que 700
apprentis l'état doit montrer l'exemple
et iliad est formidable métier dans la
fonction publique qui peuvent donner de
formidables maître d'apprentissage pour
que ces jeunes aillent dans la fonction
publique ou ailleurs parce qu'il faudra
toujours passer des concours exercer ces
métiers là on doit faire des efforts on
doit aussi avoir quelques contrats aidés
qui permettent à des associations de
mieux vivre et d'accompagner l'action
publique mais il faut peut-être aussi
travailler c'est ce que fait par exemple
très bien dire à mes conneries avec
catherine kate des raies et françois
ministère de la rue sur par exemple les
secteurs marchands un secteur associatif
l'économie sociale et solidaire on a des
tas de choses à faire parce que ces
jeunes valent le coup d'ailleurs
question parce que gérard là je vais
bientôt commencer la séance c'est le
temps de la route distribution a dit
françois hollande vous y croyez ou aussi
moi je crois que le plus dur est passé
c'était très dur il fallait beaucoup de
courage pour tenir ce cap là et que
on ne peut pas se réjouir maintenant
parce qu'il ya trop de chômeurs et qu'on
pense à chacun d'entre eux qui cherchent
la formation professionnelle la
reconversion le bon le bon endroit pour
aller se présenter
travaillons encore davantage à
l'accompagnement des chemins il nous
reste quelques secondes les chiffres de
l' ocde sont plutôt bons ils vont dans
votre sens finalement ils sont plutôt
bons il annonce que 10 et de s'aider eux
donnent de bons chiffres
le l'observatoire international du
travail aussi donc c'est plutôt bon mais
c'est pas suffisant pour arrêter
l'action publique comme ça il faut qu'on
continue il ya trop de chômeurs en
france merci beaucoup a dit ce que je
voulais c'est évidemment regagner le
bord des ministres à nos quelques
secondes la séance va commencer ma si
madame la ministre je vous disais tout à
l'heure en présentation onze questions
aujourd'hui il y à des questions sur
notamment les chiffres du chômage deux
questions très importantes notamment
d'elisabeth la mûre pour le nouveau
groupe qui s'appelle les républicains
les anciens ump qui se font appeler donc
les républicains michel biau aussi
également pour le codage c'est faudra
une question sur le chômage c'est parti
on ira collectées sur la glisse mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement tu vous rappelle que la
séance est retransmise en direct sur
france 3 et public sénat j'appelle
chacun à respecter son temps d'ailleurs
vous entraîner à la maîtrise du temps
donc c'est un exercice utile la parole
est d'abord notre collègue nathalie
goulet pour le groupe union des
démocrates et indépendants union
centriste vous avez la parole ma chère
collègue monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs mais les ministres mes chers
collègues l'arabie saoudite recrute 8
bourreau
au terme d'une offre d'emploi diffusées
sur les grands médias internationaux
pour procéder aux décapitations et aux
amputations demain conformément à la
charia la situation dramatique
du du bloqueur
raif badaoui est dans toutes les
mémoires je sais que le président de la
république lorsqu'il était à ryad a
évoqué a évoqué le cas notre pays est
très liée à l'arabie saoudite au terme
de relation économique exponentielle et
cela ne doit pas faire oublier la
situation des droits de l'homme et le
combat contre un comportement indigne
pour tout dire moyenâgeux
il se trouve que je préside le groupe
d'amitié avec les pays du golfe que je
connais bien cette région et que nos
relations économiques encore une fois ne
saurait faire oublier les les problèmes
des droits de l'homme notamment
en arabie saoudite
quelles mesures comptez-vous prendre
monsieur le ministre face à cette
situation notre pays est celui des
rafales mais c'est aussi celui des
droits de l'homme je remercie merci pour
vous répondre la parole est aux
messieurs mathias fekl
secrétaire d'état vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
président ce le président mesdames et
messieurs sénatrices et sénateurs madame
la sénatrice nathalie goulet vous
interroger le gouvernement sur un sujet
gravissime je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs
que ce sujet appelle l'humour
vous évoquez des condamnations à mort et
vous évoquez des peines atroce dont fait
l'objet aujourd'hui un blogueur à savoir
une longue condamnations de prison
assortis de 1000 coups de fouet la
france fidèle à sa tradition a dénoncé
ces situations et le président de la
république vous l'avez rappelé lorsqu'il
a été de manière inédite invité au
conseil de coopération du golfe s'est
exprimé de la manière on ne peut plus
clair sur ce sujet en rappelant le
combat permanent de la france pour
l'abolition de la peine de mort c'est le
combat de victor hugo de françois
mitterrand de robert badinter qui tous
ont siégé dans cette assemblée c'est le
combat aussi
du président chirac qui s'est engagé
pour l'inscription de l'abolition de la
peine de mort dans la constitution
française et ses messages sont portés à
tous les niveaux de l'état par notre
diplomatie et l'excellence des relations
économiques le dialogue très confiant
qui existe avec l'arabie saoudite
n'exclut en rien de porter ces messages
là concernant le cas particulier de
monsieur riley de la wii le blogueur que
vous avez évoquées
encore une fois la peine est atroce les
autorités françaises appellent l'arabie
saoudite à faire preuve de clémence
notamment à la proche du pardon du
ramadan et au delà à ne plus appliquer
cette peine je vous remercie
merci
merci monsieur le ministre je voudrais
saluer monsieur le premier ministre et
je donne maintenant la parole à notre
collègue madame elisabeth lamure pour le
groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du travail et de
l'emploi monsieur le ministre une fois
encore le malaise est grand après
l'annonce lundi soir des chiffres du
chômage chacun de nous souffrent de
cette mauvaise nouvelle qui masque un
peu les timides perspectives de
croissance alors une fois encore allons
nous entendre les mêmes arguments
dilatoire pour cacher l'échec du
président de la république qui dès 2013
a conditionné lui même à la réussite de
son action à sa capacité à inverser la
courbe du chômage
une fois encore allons nous entendre le
rappel de la situation d'avant 2012
comme seule justification les chiffres
du mois d'avril parmi les plus mauvais
depuis le début du quinquennat confirme
la tendance
rien ne semble ralentir le mouvement
infernale et pire toutes les classes
d'âge sont touchées et alors qu'en
france nous dépassons allègrement les 10
% de chômeurs nos voisins allemands et
anglais connaissent des courbe
descendante à -2 6% et de plus il crée
en majorité des emplois dans des
secteurs à forte valeur ajoutée et nous
en france nous créons des emplois aidés
vous en annonces et cent mille de plus
cette année un coût de plus de 3
milliards d'euros par an pour financer
quatre cent cinquante mille contrats
aidés mais c'est dans le secteur
marchand que les emplois créeront la
richesse d'ailleurs que nous disent les
entreprises depuis six mois la
délégation aux entreprises du sénat a
rencontré chez eux plus d'une centaine
d'entrepreneurs et tous nous tiennent le
même langage moins de contraintes - de
normes moins de charges et ils nous
disent oui nous voudrions embaucher mais
de grâce lever les freins à l'embauché
or le gouvernement balance entre donner
des gages à la gauche de sa majorité et
accepter les règles de la compétitivité
d'un monde ouvert mais les français ne
vous croient plus et il ne vous suivent
plus alors comment comptez vous sortir
de ce dilemme monsieur le ministre et
j'ajouterais comme l'a rappelé notre
président bruno retailleau ne laissez
pas passer la formidable occasion de
prendre de vraies mesures en faveur de
la croissance en acceptant tout le
travail que la majorité sénatoriale a
fait sur la loi de votre collègue
monsieur macron
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
françois rebsamen
maëlys du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
elisabeth lamure
vous vous avez cité des chiffres
et j'ai noté que vous aviez indiqué que
le taux de chômage était largement
au-dessus des 10% taux de chômage dans
notre pays j'ai cru que vous n'aviez pas
entendu les informations qui venait de
tomber ce matin et qui étaient les
chiffres que l'insee venait de publier
puisque l'insee vient d'annoncer que le
taux de chômage avait reculé en france
au premier trimestre et qu'il était vous
avez tort vous avez tort
chers collègues vous avez tort de vous
moquer des chiffres qui servent de
comparaison internationale parce que ces
chiffres sont les seuls qui sont
reconnues au niveau international et
donc c'est c'est une réalité que vous ne
pouvez pas c'est une réalité que vous ne
pouvez pas nier et que je voulais vous
indiquez je pensais bien évidemment vous
alliez comme moi vous réjouir de cette
annonce et je regrette que vous ne
fassiez pas et donc que faire pour
améliorer cette situation doit faire je
le crois ce que nous faisons pour
encourager la reprise d'activité
économique et préparer nos chômeurs à
pouvoir demain par la formation être
prêt à répondre aux offres d'emplois qui
vont être présentés c'est pourquoi nous
avons mis en place un dispositif
d'emploi aidé c'est vrai dont vous avez
vous même largement que vous avez vous
même largement utilisé je suis permis de
regarder l'histoire des contrats aidés
d'étonnant le pic a été atteint sous
quelqu'un que vous aimez bien qu'il
s'agit de l'ancien premier ministre
alain juppé soit la jupe et il y avait
huit cent cinquante mille contrats aidés
et même pendant le premier semestre 2012
vous en aviez programmé
385 milles 385 milles d'ailleurs vous
avez utilisé les deux tiers vous en avez
utilisé les deux tiers d'ici le mois de
mai 2012 et donc voilà et nous mettons
en place au contraire des politiques qui
sont des politiques de soutien à
l'activité
et pour ce faire deux lois sont en
discussion en ce moment l'une qui est
porté par mon collègue emmanuel macron
qui portent sur la croissance et
l'activité est une autre que je présente
devant vous qui est celle sur le
dialogue social tout cela un but lever
les freins et redonner la confiance des
entreprises car ce sont elles qui créent
l'emploi merci monsieur le ministre n'a
pas en l'état monsieur alain bertrand
dont le vent du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole
mais si le président armada mais
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
premier ministre vous le savez monsieur
le premier ministre local pagne
raisonnée sentiment d'abandon au moins
deux partiels l'angoissent à granby nos
concitoyens se disent va-t-on vers un
deuxième au monde une deuxième phrase
déclassé dans laquelle la devise
républicaine liberté égalité fraternité
vivre et moins qu'ailleurs une espèce de
sous république affectant toutes les
qualités pour autant nous ne faisons pas
la manche vos priorités monsieur le
ministre l'emploi la relaxe le
redressement des comptes l'école la
sécurité la lutte contre le terrorisme
favorisant une république plus juste et
plus efficace nous les partageons
d'hommes mais les ruraux veut le savoir
quel avenir vous leur proposez
comment vous l'imaginez monsieur le
premier ministre vos réponses à
condition de le fait qu'il reste ou non
dans la ruralité qu'ils y crie au long
de la richesse de l'emploi des familles
qui crient leur avenir les questions qui
se posent sont simples pour dit toujours
accéder à la santé publics ou privés
pourront ils avoir des moyens de
transport se déplacer des secours aux
personnes efficaces pour 10 d'accéder à
la téléphonie mobile à l'internet or
nous le droit au développement
économique au service public ratera pour
nous les retards d'infrastructures
seront nous aider ou privées
définitivement
d'industrie d'enseignement supérieur de
culture de sport allons nous arrêter de
tout à tasser dans les villes il vous
appartient monsieur le premier ministre
de les livrer messages politiques et
stratégiques suffisants aux ruraux
france et les c4 mesures que vous avez
prises sur les rivalités notamment sur
les maisons de services au public et les
maisons de santé ne constitue pas une
réponse assez organisé est assez forte
le message doit être plus fort plus
clair traiter des 20 prochaines années
décrire une vraie stratégie m en
prespective une place durable des
ruralités dans la république française
seule une loi d'avenir monsieur le
premier ministre peut permettre au pays
peut permettre aux ruraux de savoir où
ils vont et quel avenir ils ont ils et
leurs amis maintenant de compléter la
réponse que vous avez déjà fait en
partie à plusieurs dizaines de millions
de ruraux prenez des dispositions que
vous jugerez utiles pour que ce travail
soit à gages il mener à bien avec mon
sage décision c'est indispensable
profondément républicain et juste c'est
le moment la fois le redémarre alors pas
de sous citoyens pas de souris public
parler aux héros ils vous font confiance
faites leur confiance monsieur le
premier ministre ils vous attendent
c'est le moment merci pour vous répondre
la parole et à madame sylvia pinel
ministre du logement de l'égalité des
territoires et de la ruralité merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur alain bertrand vous venez de
rappeler les inquiétudes et les
préoccupations qui sont celles des
territoires ruraux et ses préoccupations
d'ailleurs été très largement exprimée
et relayés lors des assises des
ruralités que nous avons organisée à
l'automne et vous y avez d'ailleurs été
étroitement associés ces rencontres ont
alimenté et ont nourri la réflexion du
gouvernement pour présenter un plan
d'action et plusieurs propositions
extrêmement concrètes en termes
d'aménagement équilibré du territoire en
faveur et à destination de ces
territoires annoncée par le premier
ministre lors du comité interministériel
à eau ruralité du 13 mars dernier mais
au delà des mesures il s'agit bien d'une
nouvelle approche que le vernement a
défini le premier ministre l'a rappelé
il s'agit d'avoir un nouveau regard de
tenir compte de la diversité et des
spécificités de ces territoires qui
constituent de réels atouts de réelles
opportunités pour le développement
économique de notre pays mais sans pour
autant bien sûr mais connaître leurs
difficultés et l'ambition que nous
portons pour ces territoires s'articule
autour de trois objectifs le premier
vous l'avez rappelé est de garantir
l'accès aux services publics et au
public et pour cela nous allons
accélérer le déploiement des maisons de
service public elles seront au nombre de
1000 d'ici 2016 grâce à un partenariat
avec la poste au financement des
différents opérateurs mais également sur
la santé avec le l'installation et le
déploiement des maisons
pluridisciplinaires de santé mais aussi
des aides incitatives pour
l'installation des professionnels de
santé dans les territoires dans votre
rapport sur l'hyper ruralité vous aviez
évoqué combien la question de
l'ingénierie et de l'appui technique aux
collectivités étaient nécessaires pour
développer des projets structurants dans
l'aménagement du territoire nous avons
repris cette idée à travers le
dispositif et des bref vous le voyez
monsieur le sénateur beaucoup de mesures
qui portent un projet une ambition pour
ces territoires la ruralité constitue
une préoccupation forte du gouvernement
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
augmenté la detr de 200 millions à
destination des projets de ces
territoires l'ambition du gouvernement
pour accompagner et aider les
collectivités l'ensemble des acteurs est
présente et sera bien sûr à vos côtés
dans vos territoires pour porter cette
ambition parce que oui les ruralité font
partie de la république merci madame la
ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
joël labbé pour le groupe écologiste
avait la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
mes chers collègues sénatrices et
sénateurs ma question qui concerne
l'agriculture et l'élevage s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture il
existe aujourd'hui un fort débat autour
du pic du prix de l'alimentation qu'il
s'agisse des difficultés des
agriculteurs et éleveurs de la nécessité
d'offrir aux consommateurs une
alimentation de qualité à des prix
abordables pour tous ou encore la
question des marges des distributeurs je
vais me concentrer aujourd'hui pour ma
part sur l' écoute inhérentes à la
transition agricole que nous avons
initié fortement ici comme à l'assemblée
grâce à la loi sur l'avenir la loi pour
l'agroécologie que vous avez porté
monsieur le ministre en termes dago
écologie l'agriculture biologique ou
organiques comme chez nos voisins
anglo-saxons représente l'un des modèles
on entend encore trop souvent dire que
l'agriculture biologique est trop cher
et qu'elle offre de moins bon rendement
que l'agriculture conventionnelle
s'il y a une part de vérité c'est
évidemment critiquable
aujourd'hui plusieurs études montrent
que le différentiel en termes de
rendement peut même être inférieure à
10% pour une agriculture bien mener une
nouvelle méta étude qui vient de sortir
aujourd'hui qui a été menée par
l'université de washington va également
dans ce même sens ce que l'on oublie en
revanche de prendre en compte la plupart
du temps ce sont ce que l'on appelle les
externalités négatives associées à
l'agriculture conventionnelle
7,16 externalités qui ont un coût
pollution des eaux ingestion de produits
phytosanitaires par les consommateurs
maladies professionnelles des
agriculteurs perte de biodiversité
dégradation des sols et en parallèle les
amines les aménités positive celle là
qui sont apportées par l'agriculture
biologique et qui ont une valeur la
restauration évidemment de la qualité
des sols notamment en matière or
matières organiques la filtration des
eaux l'amélioration de la qualité
nutritionnelle
la préservation de la biodiversité des
écosystèmes
l'intensification de l'emploi en cette
période la revitalisation rurale cher
collègue alain bertrand le maintien des
paysages nous avons besoin que l'état se
penche sérieusement sur le calcul
économique associée à ces externalités
qu'elles soient positives ou négatives
et chiffres en outre que si réellement
le foot de tous ses bénéfices et ma
question monsieur le président de la
transition alors ce que nous on attend
monsieur le ministre si vous le pouviez
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable
engagement au nom du gouvernement de
faire mener cette étude exact exhaustive
économique et lorsque l'on aura à
décider ce sera aussi si on déchiffre je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire la forêt vous avez la
parole monsieur le président le sénateur
vous avez dans votre question qui était
longue fait un certain nombre de
remarques et d' analyse
complète me dit le premier ministre dans
ce télé mans vous avez parlé à la fois
des enjeux liés à des filières animales
en particulier je le dis et je les dis
ce matin dans une commission au sénat
les filières animales aujourd'hui que ça
sent la viande bovine ou la viande
porcine connaissent des difficultés de
prix extrêmement importante il y aura
des décisions à prendre de
réorganisation d'organisation et de
soutien ces filières mais je le dis
aujourd'hui on est dans une phase de
difficultés
c'est le premier point le deuxième c'est
ce débat sur les externalités positives
ou plutôt sur le fait que l'agriculture
soyons aussi honnête a eu des
conséquences sur la pollution de
l'environnement et ça c'est constater
avec différentes manifestations je vais
pas revenir sur ce qui s'était passé en
bretagne les caisses algues vertes sur
le fait qu'il ya des pollutions des
nappes à la fois phréatiques sur des
rivières sur le fait que les pesticides
c'est un sujet un jour ou l'autre de
toute façon dans le débat public y aura
à avoir des débats et apporter ces
débats donc on doit faire tout pour que
l'activité agricole garde sa dimension
économique
productif parce que sinon on a des
problèmes derrière d'alimentation et
d'accès alimentation et en même temps on
doit développer des stratégies de
performance environnementale
parce que de toute façon elle ne pourra
pas être durable si on n'est pas capable
de les intégrer donc au delà de votre
question sur le bio de manière plus
spécifique sur lequel je vous annonce
qu'on fera une étude justement pour les
anémies t positive de l'agriculture
biologique et sur lequel je peux vous
dire que selon les productions on peut
les entre -10 c'est vrai voir
équivalente sur le tournesol en bio vous
pouvez avoir des rendements équivalents
mais vous pouvez aller jusqu'à moins 40
mois 60% sur des céréales par exemple
comme le blé donc dans ce débat il faut
qu'on soit capable de porter un projet
agricole vous l'avez dit sur
l'agroécologie qui intègre la bio bien
sûr mais qui va au delà parce que c'est
un débat qui concerne tout le monde et
l'agriculture et son avenir donc sur ce
sujet je veux le dire il y aura donc un
rapport sur la vie culture bio et ses
évolutions mais l'agriculture bio aussi
à s'intégrer dans des stratégies
collectives plus important je pense en
particulier sur la question de
l'utilisation de la photosynthèse
l'agriculture bio aujourd'hui elle peut
être tout à fait dépasser par des
modèles agro écologiques qui utilise
beaucoup plus la photosynthèse que
l'agriculture biologique donc dans ce
débat c'est pas simplement faux cocu et
là je compte lui il faut sortir
uniquement de l'idée qui a deux
solutions le conventionnel ou
l'agriculture bio on our une nouvelle
voie elle doit être celle vers laquelle
nous devons nous rassembler car la
france a beaucoup d'atouts
merci
à part on est maintenant notre collègue
michel billaut pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adressera monsieur le ministre du
travail de l'emploi monsieur le ministre
selon pôle emploi le chômage a connu une
nouvelle progression au mois d'avril si
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
françois hollande qui déclarait l'année
dernière clermont ferrand si le chômage
ne baisse pas d'ici à 2017 je n'ai eu
aucune raison d'être candidat ou aucune
chance d'être réélu mais c'est surtout
une très mauvaise nouvelle pour les
chercheurs d'emploi quand le chômage de
longue durée augmente de 10 2% en un an
ainsi et l'insee ne peut contester ce
chiffre ce sont 2 33 millions de
personnes qui pointent à pôle emploi
depuis plus de 12 mois c'est
insupportable
la seule crise de la zone euro explique
de moins en moins cette situation ce
sont davantage les vieilles recettes
utilisées soit disant pour combattre le
chômage qui en sont la cause où sont
ainsi les effets promis de cic et du
pacte de responsabilité des 41 milliards
d'euros de réductions d'impôts et de
cotisations sociales accordées aux
entreprises en vue de les inciter à
embaucher et investir ces cadeaux
fiscaux accordés principalement aux
grandes entreprises sans réelle
contrepartie n'ont d'autre résultat que
l'augmentation des dividendes des
actionnaires de plus pour financer en
partie ses crédits d'impôt vous
contraignez les collectivités
territoriales à réduire l'emploi public
et associatif et à baisser fortement
leurs investissements
ainsi la baisse des dotations de l'état
aux collectivités entraînera selon
plusieurs études et notamment celle
conduite par l'association des maires de
france une réduction minimum de 25 % de
leurs investissements d'ici 2017
affaiblissant ainsi la faible reprise de
la croissance dans la même veine de la
réduction de dépenses publiques le porte
un rapport sur les trains intercités qui
préconise l'abandon de nombreuses
dessertes ferroviaires aux bénéfices
sans doute des autocars macron
provoquera s'il est appliqué de
nouvelles pertes d'emplois à la sncf il
fragilisera également l'industrie
ferroviaire en france pourtant un
fleuron de notre pays par d'importantes
baisses de commandes en tant
qu'actionnaire l'état de rester qu'il
assume bien mal la situation d'areva en
est un triste exemple alors que ce
groupe souffre depuis de nombreuses
années de sous capitalisation chronique
la vente à la découpe et la suppression
de 4000 postes en france sont présentées
aujourd'hui que les seules solutions
pour sauver le groupe c'est une
aberration pour ce qui concerne un
secteur stratégique et la sûreté
nucléaire l'état montre ainsi
malheureusement à l'exemple il faut sans
cesse baisser le fameux coût du travail
et permettre les licenciements de masse
et pour cela tout est bon facilitation
du droit de licencier casse des
prud'hommes abaissement des seuils
sociaux c'est cette mauvaise politique
qui est la cause de l'augmentation
massive du chômage il y a déjà un an les
économies du corbeau notation
affirmaient les mesures d'austérité
imposé au pays en échange de l'aide
accordée par le fmi à l'économie et à la
croissance en plus d'augmenter les
inégalités socio-économiques yoplait
monsieur le venice quand le gouvernement
va-t-il enfin conduire une politique de
gauche en faveur de la croissance et de
l'emploi
l'apparent le cas monsieur le ministre
du travail de l'emploi vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur michel guillou
j'écoutais le réquisitoire auquel vous
voulez le lévrier je me disais que tout
ce qui est excessif est insignifiant
mais je ne voudrais pas je ne voudrais
pas me limiter à ce genre de réponse
mais c'est vrai qu'un mais c'est vrai
que c'est vrai qu'à vous entendre nous
avons l'impression de vivre dans un pays
qui connaît l'austérité et je voudrais
le dire ici la politique qui est menée
par ce gouvernement est une politique de
redressement de l'économie française
elle ne passe pas par l'austérité si il
en faut la preuve je pourrais vous citer
quelques chiffres qui vous le
démontrerai dans ce pays en 2014 il y a
eu une augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
des ménages de plus de 1% est ce que
vous connaissez beaucoup de pays où il
ya l'austérité où il y à une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages
d'autre part il y a en ce moment une
reprise économique qui arrivent et les
annonces ce matin de la banque de france
les annonces de la banque de france
montrent que la politique qui est menée
de redressement porte ses fruits alors
effectivement et là vous avez raison il
ya un décalage incontestable entre les
annonces de la reprise économique et la
réalité sur le terrain vécu en matière
d'emploi et ce décalage nous essayons de
le combler comment par la formation
indispensable et prioritaire des
chômeurs et vous le savez cette grande
avancée que constitue le compte
personnel de formation permet pour la
première fois à ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin c'est à dire à ceux qui sont
chômeurs et notamment aux chômeurs de
longue durée qui est un problème qui
concerne toutes les formations
politiques et qui n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
quand on regarde les chiffres permettre
à 200 mille cent soixante mille très
exactement demandeurs d'emploi d'accéder
demain nous l'espérons à l'emploi en
améliorant l'adéquation entre les offres
d'emploi qui existent et la demande
d'emploi pourquoi parce qu'il ya encore
trop d'emplois non pourvus dans notre
pays et pour qu'il y à une meilleure
adéquation il faut qu'il y ait une
meilleure formation et tout est fait en
ce sens pour améliorer la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi enfin je voudrais
ajouter que les offres yves rancourt
loin sont en progression les offres
d'emploi sont en progression et nous
verrons dans les prochains mois que
l'année 2015 sera meilleure que l'année
2014 merci la parole est de notre
collègue jean jacques filleul pour le
groupe socialiste avait la parole oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports cher
collègue monsieur le ministre vous avez
commandé un rapport sur les trains des
clips territoire en novembre dernier
afin de clarifier l'offre est de
redresser le modèle économique de ce
service ferroviaire aujourd'hui maillon
faible entre tgv et ter
la commission constituée a décrit sans
complaisance la situation actuelle d'été
ôter son rapport montrent qu'il ya
urgence à intervenir il était
indispensable de surcroît de tenir un
discours de vérité pour permettre au
gouvernement d'agir en fait
l'appellation unique de tlt cache une 30
diversité de ligne des lignes du grand
bassin parisien
des radial transversale de longues
distances dessertes interrégionales ou
des lignes de nuit sans évoquer la forte
imbrication avec les dessertes ter la
qualité de l'offre s'est profondément
dégradée au cours des dernières
décennies elle est de moins en moins
adaptées aux considérables évolution des
mobilités j'ajoute la répartition
confuse des responsabilités entre l'état
autorité organisatrice de transport pour
les tester et sncf mobilité la situation
décrite montrent qu'au fil de l'eau la
suppression détectés seront inéluctables
si rien n'est engagée par les pouvoirs
publics d'autant que le matériel roulant
de plus de 30 ans de moyenne d'âge
devient obsolète ce rapport inscrit dans
ses propositions une vision structurante
de la mobile était un marqueur de
modernité au même titre que les tgv et
les ter permettant à la plus grande
majorité des lignes tht est haute et
d'être renforcée d'avoir du matériel
roulant performants et attractifs
l'objectif étant de ne laisser aucun
territoire sans solution
toutes ces propositions passe par un
renforcement
indispensable de l'autorité
organisatrice par la création d'une
agence spécialisée
théo théo sein du ministère des
transports ce rapport contient au delà
du constat de nombreuses propositions
décisives pour l'avenir monsieur me nice
comme vous nous voulons mettre l'usager
au coeur de l'évolution de l'offre des
trains d'équilibré du territoire nous
souhaitons que ce rapport soit pris en
compte par le gouvernement est porté par
le plus grand nombre comment
envisagez-vous de l'intégrer dans la
politique des transports de voyageurs
quels sont les éclairages que vous
pouvez apporter aujourd'hui devant la
haute assemblée si vous remercie merci
la parole le cas larijani secrétaire
d'état en charge des transports vous
avez la parole pour 2 minutes 30 maximum
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur le gouvernement a effectivement
chargé une commission présidée par
philippe duron de réfléchir à l'avenir
des trains d'équilibré du territoire et
le sénat étaient représentés dans cette
commission par vous même par madame
annie guillon et par monsieur jean
vincent placé des experts ont travaillé
aux côtés des parlementaires pour ce
rapport qui a été publié la semaine
dernière je veux souligner la qualité de
ce rapport qui est sans concession mais
ça n'était pas son objectif qui fait à
la fois un constat et qui a essayé de
faire un travail aussi de comparaison
pour voir les solutions à adopter dans
d'autres pays et qui fait un certain
nombre de propositions
le constat personne ne peut s'en
exonérer est le premier des constats
c'est le déficit du fonctionnement d'été
et est aujourd'hui l'état et aux
autorités organisatrices pour l'été et
et le déficit pour l'année
1015 sera autour de 400 millions si nous
faisons rien il sera de 500 millions
d'ici d'ici deux ans et donc c'est la
première question à laquelle
naturellement il faut répondre ensuite
le constat de mettre en exergue comme
vous l'avez fait la vétusté du matériel
plus de 35 ans d'âge et puis le
caractère absolument
hétérogène de ce que l'on a mis sous la
labellisation de trains d'équilibré du
territoire puisqu'il ya là à la fois de
ses vrais des grandes lignes et qui
peuvent correspondre à la définition
initiale et puis dépôt des petits bouts
de ligne parfois une ligne qui ne
fonctionnent que le samedi à la place du
ter dans la semaine mais aussi des
trains de nuit tout cela évidemment
mérite d'être précisée vous faites
ensuite des propositions en l'état
naturellement il s'agit d'un rapport le
gouvernement va étudier ces propositions
et au mois de juin j'annoncerai une
feuille de route pourquoi parce que il y
à une imbrication forte naturellement
entre la question des ter et la question
détecter et que la perspective notamment
de réorganisation des régions suppose et
qu'il y ait un travail de concertation
qu'ils soient faits y compris avec les
futurs exécutifs des grands région il
faut aussi évidemment que l'on
réfléchisse à la question du matériel
donc les propositions le calendrier que
le gouvernement annoncera se fera autour
de trois principes le premier c'est
l'objectif de réduire le déficit le
second c'est d'avoir une le respect du
droit à la mobilité pour chacun et le
troisième de respecter l'avenir des
territoires merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant à mes collègues
lembeye trillard pour le groupe l'est
républicain
mais remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question ça va s'adresser à monsieur le
ministre alain vidalies secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche concerne notre dame des
landes
nous avons eu la loire atlantique des à
dist nous avons aux airs de beatniks
violent quand il le faut déterminer
quand ils savent qu'ils font peur à la
gauche ait peur au pouvoir
rappelons-nous les événements violents
d'il y a deux ans sur les 1600 hectares
de la zad déjà acheté pour le projet de
cet aéroport les conséquences sont
encore bien visibles la route
départementale numéro 2 181 est fermé
depuis deux ans cas unique en europe
depuis l'ex yougoslavie
seras tu aimerais ouverte un jour
une présence humaine est bien là 100 à
200 personnes installées dans des abris
de fortune
quelques fermes occupées comme une
cohabitation qui s'est installée avec
des agriculteurs réfractaires au projet
une économie dite et au progrès une
économie dite nouvelle s'y développent
tout cela sous les yeux des habitants
des communes proches scandalisé par
cette zone de non droit on a
l'impression que ce laisser-aller va
fixer une population pour longtemps les
élus parlent d'un laxisme avérée des
services de l'état et pendant ce temps
là les sommes fabuleuses sont tout
l'intérêt général sont dépensés à
proximité de l'aéroport actuel nantes
atlantique comme si le transfert était
acquis
déplacement du marché d'intérêt national
de nantes le seconde france après régis
coup plus de 70 millions d'euros
projet de construction sur le même site
d'un nouveau chu
qui dans l'axé des pistes de l'actuel
aéroport à moins de trois kilomètres du
but de de la propriété ne pourra
peut-être pas ouvrir dans les conditions
normales compte tenu des nuisances
vraisemblable que valuation un petit
milliard d'euros
les chiffres du développement du
transport aérien sont pourtant sans
appel et légitime totalement cette
infrastructure nationale et je ne me
rappelais 3 doublement préfet prévisible
du trafic dans les trois dans les quinze
ans
31000 avions à construire d'ici 2030 par
les deux plus grands constructeurs a
évoqué à votre question
monsieur le ministre de question allez
vous rendent possible la circulation sur
les routes autour de la trame de landes
comptez vous un jour sortir du dilemme
politique dans lesquelles vous enferme
vos alliés verts pour qu'enfin les
travaux commencent sachant que vous
n'avez plus guère les moyens de revenir
en arrière merci merci monsieur criard
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur alain vidalies la parole
monsieur le mini
merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur le projet a fait l'objet d'une
large concertation publique et la
commission du dialogue qui a été mise en
place en 2012 a confirmé le bien-fondé
de la réalisation de ce futur aéroport
tout en suggérant des études
complémentaires pour un diagnostic
partagé et des pistes d'amélioration
deux études ont ici été réalisées l'une
sur les nuisances sonores dans
l'hypothèse d'un maintien de l'aéroport
actuel elle conclut que le nombre
d'habitants soumis aux bruits passerait
à près de 80000 l'autre sur un
réaménagement de l'aéroport actuel le
coût des travaux pour permettre le
développement de l'aéroport de nantes
dans le respect des règles de sécurité
serait proche de celui du futur aéroport
sans réduire les nuisances ces études
sont soumises un débat contradictoire
toutes les hypothèses données
méthodologie de ces études ont été
expliqués et rendue publique et le
gouvernement est attaché à respecter
scrupuleusement les réglementations
applicables à ce projet plus de 50
recours déposés par les opposants ont
déjà été rejetée par la justice par
ailleurs des mesures de compensation
environnementales ont été précisées et
complétées et des prescriptions
exigeante et ambitieuse au maître
d'ouvragé ont été inscrits dans les
arrêtés loi sur l'eau et espèce protégée
pour garantir l'efficacité de ces
prescriptions l'état s'est imposé une
obligation de résultat
le projet de l'aéroport éconduit dans le
respect du droit dans un souci de
transparence et de dialogue le
gouvernement n'a pas l'intention de
débuter les travaux avant le jugement
des recours juridiques actuellement
déposés qui sont tous en voie de
finalisation concernant les
comportements sur la zone tous les actes
délictueux commis par les opposants
radicaux à l'aéroport dès lors qu'ils
sont portés à la connaissance des forces
de l'ordre font l'objet de procédures
judiciaires
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole et à madame 2010 xylo pour le
groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
madame la ministre votre intense
activité pour le collège pourrait faire
oublier à certains que vous êtes aussi
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
il n'en est rien vous n'avez ménagé ni
votre attention ni l'ambition politique
du gouvernement pour la vie étudiante la
recherche et la valorisation de la
culture scientifique le développement
universitaire et l'innovation l'impact
du numérique sur la pédagogie les
formations ainsi les derniers décrets
d'application de la loi et serre sont
publiés et nous allons débattre des
rapports relatifs à sa mise en oeuvre à
échéance de deux ans pour la première
fois cette année les dotations ont été
signifiées aux établissements sur
l'analyse de leurs comptes
administratifs 2014 ce qui garantit un
meilleur ajustement de leurs besoins
financiers et à leurs capacités de
réalisation une étude de l'igaenr a
permis d'autoriser certains
établissements à utiliser une part de
leurs fonds de roulement fonctionnement
introduisant ainsi une meilleure
consommation de l'argent public qui n'a
pas vocation à être théorisé sans fin au
retour du congrès de l'unef des états
généraux de la pédagogie menées par les
associations étudiantes
vous avez lancé la concertation du plan
national de vie étudiante après la
réforme des bourses en 2013 2014 le
lancement d'un plan de quarante mille
nouveaux logements étudiants la caution
locative étudiante votre soutien mon
amendement pour renforcer la réussite
des étudiants salariés voilà bien des
inscriptions dans la volonté du
président de la république
faire de la jeunesse une priorité de son
gouvernement
la semaine dernière rejoignant à
strasbourg la conférence des présidents
d'université qui tenait colloque sur le
thème universités 3.0 nouveaux enjeux
nouvelle échelle à l'ère numérique vous
avez loué notre université qui s'ouvre
toujours plus et mieux pour enrichir ses
méthodes et sa mixité pour partager ces
trésors de connaissances et de culture
vous avez réaffirmé l'objectif de 25 %
d'une classe d'âge au niveau master et
50% au niveau licence pour cela le
numérique est un facteur d'accélération
et de valorisation des savoirs bon c'est
votre rituel ministre si beaucoup a été
fait pour démocratiser l'enseignement
supérieur et répondre aux défis de
l'avenir comment soutenir les
innovations et maîtriser les nouvelles
sciences issus des technologies pour la
rentrée prochaine comment donner à
chacun l'envié de se dépasser et de
coopérer pour une france de la réussite
et de l'égalité au service de
l'excellence merci pour vous répondre la
parole est à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche il avait la
parole madame la ministre merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice dominique
gillot merci pour cette question qui me
permet de revenir sur l'ambition du
gouvernement en matière d'enseignement
supérieur et de recherche
cette ambition c'est d'abord une
ambition de réussite et vous avez eu
raison de le rappeler il faut le dire
haut et fort nous avons l'ambition
d'atteindre d'ici 10 ans les 50 % d'une
classe d'âge qu'ils soient diplômés de
la licence dans l'enseignement supérieur
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour saluer dans
le public les lycéens du lycée d'urzy de
villemandeur à qui je souhaite de très
bonnes épreuves du bac bientôt et de
rejoindre très vite cet enseignement
supérieur mais j'y reviens
pour pouvoir réaliser cet objectif il
nous faut notamment lever les freins
financiers puisque c'est bien sûr les
conditions de vie qui parfois peuvent
bloquer les jeunes lorsqu'il s'agit de
poursuivre leurs études et c'est la
raison pour laquelle depuis 2000 nous
avons veillé à consacrer beaucoup
d'argent aux bourses étudiantes 450
millions d'euros permettant en
particulier à 130 mille étudiants qui
auparavant de bénéficier de strictement
rien de bénéficier au minimum de 1000
euros par an c'est donc un progrès
considérable tout comme ont été
revalorisées l'ensemble des bourses
étudiantes les logements étudiants vous
en avait parlé
l'objectif vous l'avez rappelé quarante
mille logements étudiants d'ici 2017
12000 déjà réalisé et nous allons
continuer et puis il faut aller plus
loin c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
lancé cette concertation sur la vie
étudiante avec les associations
d'étudiants les établissements les
collectivités qui doit aboutir d'ici
l'été pour que de premières mesures
soient adoptées à la rentrée qu'il
s'agisse de mesures de simplification
des démarches administratives portant
sur les demandes de bourses de logement
ou le parcours du combattant qui est
souvent celui des étudiants étrangers
qu'il s'agisse d'améliorer les
conditions de vie des étudiants qui
travaillent en développement en
particulier sur les campus de l'emploi
de bonne qualité je pense à l'emploi
dans les bibliothèques universitaires
qui permettra aussi d'ouvrir ses
bibliothèques plus tardivement nous
aurons donc des mesures sur ce point à
la rentrée et qu'il s'agisse enfin
d'inciter et de valoriser l'engagement
étudiant notamment grâce à l'année de
césure qui sera désormais permise et
puis vous avez évoqué le numérique pour
aller vite oui c'est vrai il faut aussi
moderniser la pédagogie au sein de
l'université avec des méthodes plus
interactif et les universités françaises
avec le développement des mouches ces
derniers temps ont su faire preuve aussi
de leur rayonnement de leur capacité à
influencer mon pass francophone je
conclurai en disant que ici même à paris
demain je recevrai 30 ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche de l'espace francophone pour
développer toujours plus c'est ti
éducation merci merci l'ami la parole
est maintenant notre collègue delphine
bataille pour le groupe socialiste avait
la parole ma chère collègue merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre du travail de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social
monsieur le ministre cette semaine les
organisations syndicales et patronales
ont été entendus par le premier ministre
sur ces propositions et sur les pistes
de travail pour favoriser l'emploi dans
les très petites entreprises et petites
et moyennes entreprises ces
consultations pour encourager l'activité
et l'embauchent constitue une priorité
pour lutter contre le chômage et
concerne tous les territoires de la
république
beaucoup a déjà été fait et de nouveau
levier d'action sont à l'étude relations
entre les sous traitants et donneurs
d'ordres délais de paiement concurrence
déloyale des travailleurs détachés
renouvellement des contrats de travail à
durée déterminée lors de ces rencontres
bilatérales
le contrat de travail unique
régulièrement relancé par certains
économistes et par le patronat a fait
lui aussi l'objet de discussions outre
le fait qu'une telle réforme serait
difficile à mettre en oeuvre d'ailleurs
au monsieur sarkozy qui l'avait mis dans
son programme en 2007 il y a finalement
renoncé
l'utilité de cette réforme n'est à ce
jour nullement démontrée le contrat
unique telle que voulue par le medef
dans son obsession de flexibilité
constitue en réalité une régression
sociale est un non sens économique
comme le démontre une étude européenne
et contrairement aux allégations de nos
collègues de droite les salariés
français sous contrat à durée
indéterminée sont déjà nettement moins
protégé qu'en allemagne un pays modèle
pour certains un tel contrat ne ferait
au fond qu accroître l'insécurité et la
précarité en matière d'emploi générant
notamment des difficultés d'accès au
crédit immobilier au logement locatif
lourd être en finalité un effet négatif
sur la consommation des ménages et sur
notre croissance économique le
gouvernement présentera le 9 juin
prochain les mesures arrêtées après
consultation des partenaires sociaux à
votre question vous avez vous monsieur
le ministre nous indiquait que le
contrat de travail à durée
indéterminée ne sera pas remise en cause
au profit d'un contrat de travail unique
plus précaires merci pour vous répondre
la parole est aux ministres du travail
et de l'emploi
ils avaient la parole mon cher ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice delphine bataille et je
remercie de votre question effectivement
avec le premier ministre nous avons reçu
avec emmanuel macron autour du premier
ministre l'ensemble des partenaires
sociaux cette semaine
délégation qui était composé
organisations patronales et syndicales
et je voudrais rappeler que depuis
l'élection de françois hollande le
dialogue social a été érigée en méthode
de gouvernement cela applique deux
exigences la première l'écouté le
respect des partenaires sociaux tel n'a
pas toujours été le cas dans le passé
mais nous avons la convoque nous avons
nous la conviction que c'est en avançant
avec eux que les réformes peuvent donner
des résultats et s'inscrivent
durablement dans le paysage le français
encourager l'activité et l'embauchent
dans les pme tpe constituent
effectivement une priorité pour lutter
contre le chômage vous l'avez rappelé et
cela c'est là que secret majoritairement
les emplois beaucoup a été fait déjà que
soit l'allègement du coût du travail les
mesures de simplification qui était
attendu ou bien encore le soutien à
l'activité l'apprentissage mais il faut
aller plus loin et rechercher de
nouveaux leviers pour agir pour l'emploi
concrètement le gouvernement annoncera
les mesures arrêtées le 9 juin après la
tenue d'un
d'une réunion d'un conseil des ministres
restreint autour du premier ministre et
du président de la république l'heure
est toujours à la concertation et nous
finissons autour du premier ministre les
concertations en ce moment mais pour
répondre précisément à votre question je
peux d'ores et déjà vous assurer qu'il
ne sera pas question de remettre en
cause le cdi ni le contrat de travail au
sens large je veux dire par là que nous
avons la chance d'avoir en france toutes
les formes de contrats de travail et que
c'est justement cette diversité des
formes de contrats de travail qui
constitue une chance pour les employeurs
et pour les salariés bien évidemment
réformer dans et par le dialogue social
est un choix qu'a fait le gouvernement
ce n'est pas un choix géométrie variable
par conséquent toucher au contrat de
travail ne pourrait être envisagée
qu'avec l'accord des organisations
syndicales et leur soutien tel n'est pas
le cas et donc je voulais par ma réponse
vous vous assurez que le dialogue social
constitue bien un des axes du
gouvernement merci monsieur le ministre
ta parole est maintenant à notre
collègue caroline cayeux pour le groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur vidal east ministre chargé des
transports de la mer et de la pêche
monsieur le ministre permettez moi de
m'exprimer en tant qu'élu des
territoires comme vous tous mes chers
collègues et plus particulièrement
françois commeinhes sénateur de
l'hérault mais aussi en tant que
président de l'association villes de
france sur le sujet capital pour nos
collectivités comme pour nos administrés
des trains d'équilibré du territoire ou
les trains intercités le ferroviaire
régional et inter régionale joue
effectivement un rôle majeur non
seulement dans la mobilité des personnes
sur le territoire national mais aussi
sur les déplacements des actifs et aussi
des étudiants souvent pour leur
formation la pérennité de ces trains
d'équilibré du territoire semble
condamnée à l'issue de l'étude dans le
cadre de la commission durant ce rapport
préconise en effet fermetures de lits
allègement d'un certain nombre de
dessertes je pense à la liaison bordeaux
nice alors que la démographie des
territoires traversés et souvent
positives cette offre devait être
profondément revue essentiellement par
la substitution d'autocars le transfert
aux régions où la cessation de ces
lignes les élus des territoires que nous
représentons estimons premièrement qu'il
ne peut pas y avoir de démembrement sans
un débat préalable devant la
représentation nationale
deuxièmement en raison de l'abandon
programmé par l'état du principe de
conventionnement de ce service public
nous demandons une ouverture rapide de
l'offre d'exploitation à la concurrence
de toutes les lignes concernées dans des
conditions de transparence renforcée
nous dénonçons également le tout tgv
logique privilégiant un polycentrisme
parisien et allant à l'encontre d'un
aménagement équilibré du territoire
quant au remplacement de ses trains par
des services d'autocars à l'heure où la
france se prépare à accueillir la
conférence sur le climat au mois de
décembre cela nous semble aller à
l'encontre des principes essentiels du
développement durable monsieur le
ministre l'état s'apprêtent ils oui ou
non demain à renoncer à un outil
efficace pour maintenir un maillage
cohérent de nos territoires monsieur le
ministre pouvez vous nous dire si vous
confirmer ces annonces et si les
intentions du gouvernement en la matière
était avérée de bien vouloir par respect
pour les élus et les populations qui
vivent sur ces territoires y surseoir
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état aux transports vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice la situation qui est
évoqué par le rapport qui m'a été remis
au gouvernement est le résultat d'une
convention qui a été passé en 2010
le constat c'est que la question du
déficit financier n'a pas été examinée
en 2010 que le matériel qui a
aujourd'hui 33 ans il avait déjà trente
ans que personne s'en est soucié et que
malheureusement et voudrait bien partir
de là à 100 que j'insiste trop partager
le fardeau avec moi à partir de là il ya
aujourd'hui une situation
urgence
jamais contrairement ce que vous avez
dit le gouvernement n'a annoncé et je
m'inscris en faux qu'il allait procéder
à un des conventionnements ça n'est pas
juste le gouvernement qui est chargée
qui autorités organisatrices entend
effectivement dans un nouveau cadre
parvenir à la signature d'une nouvelle
convention
le constat si on veut regarder dans le
détail c'est très hétérogène mais
ces lignes sont déficitaires pas toutes
certaines le sens d'une manière
acceptable certaines lignes on a un
déficit qui est de 5 euros par voyageur
et par jour ah c'est pas réjouissant
mais il ya une mission de service public
qui rentrent qu'elle remplit certaines
lignes annonce un déficit de 275 euros
par jour et par voyageur est ce qu un
élu responsable et j'ai envie de dire ce
qui souvent nous rappelle à l'exigence
de la maîtrise de la dépense publique
pourrait peut-être prendre un peu aussi
en considération cet aspect de la
problématique
275 euros par jour et par voyageur c'est
une vraie question et on essaye d'y
répondre ce rapport n'engage pas le
gouvernement le parlement a été
immédiatement saisie puisque les
commissions compétentes entend organiser
un débat à ma demande sur ce rapport et
je ferai connaître la feuille de route
vous avez eu raison de rappeler les
principes les principes ils seront à
essayer de maîtriser le déficit
respecter les territoires et assurer le
droit à la mobilité et j'espère que sur
ces principes ou serait au rendez vous
merci monsieur lui nice
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues merci nous en avons fini
et cliquez sur d'actualité au
gouvernement et je vois que votre
antenne entraînement s'améliore quand je
vois le temps tu es donc suspendre la
séance et sera repris à 16h15 pour la
suite de la discussion du projet de loi
relatif aux renseignements il nous reste
96 amendements à examiner la séance est
suspendue
on a fini avec la séance des questions
d'actualité au sénat place à on refait
la séance